Congress meantime has a midnight
deadline to avoid a partial government
shutdown after President Trump rejected
a Senate budget deal the news shook up
Wall Street where the Dow Jones
Industrials lost another 464 points
House Republicans then backed mr. Trump
on a party-line vote to add billions in
spending for the president's border wall
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill waiting
for a Senate vote later today Nancy good
morning good morning you know just 24
hours ago it looked like the president
was going to accept this stopgap
spending deal and look for his wall
funding somewhere else but then he
decided that he wanted congressional
Republicans to go to the mat for that
wall funding instead and a shutdown went
from unlikely to potentially unavoidable
House Republicans gambled and won last
night the motion is adopted without
objection passing a spending bill that
includes the five billion dollars in
border wall funding the president
demands we need the wall the Democrats
know it everybody knows it but the
victory will likely be short-lived this
idea of a wall is dumb because Democrats
can vote the bill down in the Senate the
Trump temper tantrum may produce a
government shutdown it will not get him
his wall with about 400,000 federal
workers at risk of being furloughed
Republican leaders thought they had
talked the president out of last week's
shutdown stance I am proud to shut down
the government for border security but
then conservatives accused mr. Trump of
caving on his signature issue the wall
the wall wall has to be built if we're
not going to fight now when are we gonna
fight by midday yesterday the president
had summoned Republican House leaders to
the White House to say he would veto any
bill that did not include funding for
the wall I've made my position very
clear any measure that funds the
government must include border security
has to now with time running out no one
seems to know what Congress can pass and
what the president will sign 5.7 billion
dollars for a wall that won't even work
no thanks
the Senate comes back into session at
noon today to vote and a lot of Senators
thought that their work was done for the
year they left and now they're on
flights racing back on one of the
busiest travel days of the year
the President himself was slated to head
to Florida tomorrow Lago today but his
aides say that he won't be traveling if
there's a shutdown
Yael or Nancy thank you